today we can be looking at sort of
microSD composition patterns more to the
point monolith decomposition patterns so
patterns that you make make use of when
moving towards a micro service
architecture my name's Sam Newman I've
written a book about micro services
which should be there there is and I
also run my own training and advisory
firm if you don't know more about what I
do you can find information on my
website and I'm in the process of
actually writing a brand new book called
moneth - micro services which hopefully
should be out sort of towards the end of
the summer there's more information my
website you can see it you can read an
early version over there what we're
going to be sharing what I'm going to be
sharing with you today is some of the
themes from that book and some of the
ideas from that book there's a lot more
detail here but I wanted to give you a
bit of a taste and really I think deal
with kind of a fundamental truth about
micro service architectures which is for
most people you are trying to transform
something you already have into a micro
service architecture yeah it's very rare
that you're starting with a blank sheet
of paper and you get to think all what
should we do today
it's not like that often you've got an
existing system that's got for whatever
reason to a state where you are
struggling to manage it always not
allowing you to do the things that you
want to do and so you're looking to
change it and of course micro services
are very very you know buzzword
compliant and you think yes I need some
of those so how do you take what you've
got now and moved to that world and I'm
going to be sharing with you a few ideas
and a few patterns associated those
migrations today because it's what we
want right we want my nice little
hexagonal micro service architecture and
as I talk about a lot one of the main
things this architecture optimizes for
is sort of reducing the cost and impact
of change they try and come up with an
architecture and a set of deployment
practices as well that allow us to make
a change to a service and deploy that a
new version of that service into a
production environment without having to
change anything else is this facet of
independent deployability this
characteristic of independent deploy
ability is key to what micro services
are about micro services are an
opinionated type of architecture one of
the opinions we have is independent
deploy ability is good
won't talk about some of the other
opinions of Micra service architecture a
bit later on
now of course micro services are most
often can something compared to the
monolith right at least we've seen the
monitors the big bad beast it's the
worst thing in the world now and I'll
pity me I've got a model if you go home
and say how was work today
well you know I don't you know it was it
was tough we had to we had to do with a
monolith it's become like some kind of
all-consuming desire to kill them on a
lift which i think is a bit of a it's a
bit ring wrongheaded actually but before
we get into that we should talk about
what we mean when we talk about a
monolith a sort of more dictionary
definition of a monolith is something is
not divisible it's something that cannot
be broken apart into pieces which
already doesn't really make sense for
the arm on its because most of our Manas
can but we typically talk about a
monolith in the in the context of
deployment so talking about normally
we're talking about a monolith as a unit
of deployment so we can think of the
classic single process monolith well we
take all of our code together and we
bundle it into a single process and that
process gets deployed and that's our
sort of deployment topology so if a
simple deployment architecture and it
normally follows that all of our data is
in one big giant database and just you
know sort of point out that this is
actually a type of distributed system
it's just a really simple one a
distributed system is one where you've
got two computers talking to each other
over about networks and this this does
fall into that bracket of course you'll
also be serving data probably up
information up onto a web page as well
therefore making it an even more
distributed system so all the codes
packaged together into a single process
or the data is stored in a single
database and it's a two type of system
architecture which has done us very well
indeed and there are lots of companies
that have been incredibly successful
building monolithic architectures even
if some of them now want to move away
from that we have variations on this
theme of course we have the modular
monolith which is embracing cutting-edge
brand new ideas from the mid 60's about
decomposition of software so where this
in this example where our code is still
all host
together in a single process but the
code is now broken down into modules
those modules can be worked on
independently potentially by different
teams and then we link those modules
together to form the running process
these ideas are sound this works really
well but it turns out that as an
industry we are extremely bad at doing
this the only way the places where it
does sort of work is when we're working
with third-party software when we're
actually pulling and think about all the
shared developer dependencies you have
that's you're using modules that have
had a defined boundary and you link with
those modules and get benefits what
we've seen to be very bad at is building
a system ourselves that we can decompose
into these modules again these IDs are
not new and it would actually do is
quite a lot of good to go back and read
the ideas of structure programming and
the work done by David Parnas others in
the early 70s so this is nice but we
still have a sort of typically a single
unit of deployment a single process that
we're dealing with this is highly
underrated for a number of my clients
when they say should I go to micro
services I say no a good modular
monolith is probably enough for many
people it gives you some benefits one of
the key benefits the good modular
decomposition can bring is the ability
for you to have teams working
independently on separate models or
modules rather you still have that
coordination effort around deployment
but this is still a much more simple
deployment topology it's a much simpler
distributed system to deal with there's
another type of model if we can consider
and that is the monolith which is say a
third party piece of software this could
be something you're installing on
premise this could be like a CRM this
could be SAP this could be Salesforce it
could be a SAS product but a piece of
software that has a high degree of
configuration and value to your company
but there is effectively something that
you buy licenses for which you can't
actively do much with apart from
configuration you can't get into the
internals of Salesforce and redesign the
architecture of that system you're sort
of beholden to the architecture and the
design as laid out by the providers so
there's lots of these are also
monolithic software and a lot of my
clients are actively building their own
software to migrate away from these
systems and a challenge always is well
how do I do an incremental migration of
effectively what is somebody else's big
black box that's arrived in my premises
and there are some things that we can do
the challenge with these types of
systems is you typically have much less
control or ability to change the
underlying system some of the techniques
we'll talk about a bit later on do
require you to have some degree of
ability to change the system there are
those some things that we can do in
these types of situations because most
of the time a lot these systems will
actually expose a database directly
which gives you some ability to do some
really dirty things if you want to just
can be very useful and they often
nowadays as well also expose an API
which opens them up for some kind of
migration techniques things like the
strangler fig pattern which we discuss a
bit later on so there are definitely
things that we can do with the third
party monolith the sort of cots product
although it's fair to say that you will
have more limitations placed upon you in
these situations we kind of had the
fourth type of monolith that we need to
talk about today and it's it's one I
suspect many of you have and in fact
many of the people that claim to have
micro service architecture this is
actually what they've got and that my
friends is a thing called the
distributed monolith which on the face
of it seems like an odd thing to say
Moloch is a single thing but you're
saying it's distributed so how can it be
a monolith no we talk about a monolith
as being something that's non divisible
hard to break apart a distributed
monolith is a distributed system that is
so coupled together that you cannot
deploy pieces of it independently and in
turn you actually tends to deploy the
whole thing together there can be a
number of reasons why you I have a
distributed monolith a lot of them have
their roots and of the the same problems
that people have building modular
software still crop up when building
these kinds of architectures if you get
your module boundaries wrong if you
don't adhere to the ideas of things like
information hiding you can end up with
very coupled architecture you'll see the
symptoms of this where you start doing
things like trying to run up very small
changes in functionality and finding
that those change in functionality
always require changes or lots of parts
of your system every now and then even
the micro service architecture you might
have some cross-cutting changes required
but when that becomes the norm you start
moving into a world
having complexity about how you deploy
your software the cost of deploying
software drastically increases the worst
situations are when basically because
it's so hard to decouple this
architecture people say well let's just
release it all together and so come your
next release okay we want to deploy one
little part of it but you know we'll
just deploy the whole thing together
because that's the only model that
actually seems to make sense to us and
doesn't that look like a lot of fun
doesn't it look like a lot of fun you've
now got 15 different teams all trying to
coordinate right on Tuesday morning
we're all going live at the same time on
your mark get set go
what what do you mean that hasn't worked
quick roll it all back phone the CTO you
know these kinds of mass deployment
activities are an absolute disaster and
are not much fun at all we end up having
with these systems a very high cost of
change and a much larger scope
deployments the larger the scope of the
deployment the more risk there is
associated with the deployment the more
chances something is going to go wrong
so this is not good right a micro
service architecture fundamentally is
all about trying to make it easier for
us to release software and distributed
monoliths they might achieve other
things for us but we have a higher cost
of change with a distributed monolith
than we would with a single process
monolith and so you may end up with sort
of the worst of both worlds this lovely
release coordination activity sometimes
this comes about because of a lack of or
not getting your service berendeys in
the right place we'll talk about how you
do that in a moment it could often come
about because of sort of release
practices so some of you may have heard
of a release practice called the release
train which sounds like an exciting form
of transportation who wouldn't want to
have a ride on the release train now the
release train actually is a technique
that can be quite useful when trying to
move organizations towards continuous
delivery the way it works is you set up
two you said Isaiah a duration and you
say that every four weeks all the
software we've built in four weeks we
release all together and the idea is is
that you actually decrease the duration
of that train and get to smaller and
smaller pieces and then eventually you
throw the rly the concept of the release
train away altogether
and move at to proper continuous
delivery and release on demand the
problem is that many people
see the released train as the goal and
the destination and we now have of
course formally specified trademarked
laminated process maps out there that
talk about how fantastic the release
train is and mentioning no names but you
know this can cause some problems
because now we have many organizations
that see as aspirational this release
technique but what it ends up doing is
it codifies and enshrines the idea that
we should release lots of software
together and even if you don't start off
with a distributed monolith you'll end
up with one if you keep doing this for
too long so whether or not you've been
told you've got to do safe do yourselves
a favor and only see the released train
as a stepping stone onto a lot of much
better ideas this idea of trying to
reduce the cost of change is really very
important probably the best summation I
think of the ideas behind some of the
ideas behind continuous delivery we're
done by John Osborne out 10 years ago
now this presentation is hard to track
down you can find the slides but if you
can dig out the original presentation
it's well worth it I think it's
available to people who sign up the
Safari platform but in two slides he
really distills down the concepts behind
continuous delivery he talks about the
cost of change so here we have a long
duration between releases the longer the
duration between each release the more
things have changed the more things that
have changed the sort of the higher the
risk of the deployment the more things
there are to go wrong more importantly
you get your software out less
frequently you have a release process
you don't use as often and therefore
there are more things to go wrong and
what sometimes happens in these
situations is the release goes badly and
people say right next time let's be even
more careful or spend a lot longer over
the next release to put some more things
in place and make sure we definitely
don't make a mistake the next release
takes even longer there's more
functionality and oh look you've got a
whole lot of problems whereas the idea
is you want to drastically reduce how
frequent I'd suggest eclis reduce how
long it takes you to get software out
you're looking at lots of small releases
of software this is what we're aiming
for
if each release is small in scope there
is less to go wrong it's easier to
reason about any issues you might have
if you have to rollback it's easier to
do you have
the ability to roll forward if any of
you have seen the accelerate state of
DevOps report and I definitely urge you
to to read that it shows very clearly
that the most high-performing IT teams
in the world they release software more
frequently than anybody else and they
have lower defect rates there used to be
this idea that you either go fast and
break stuff will go slow and steady
that's not true all the evidence now
shows us that is not true
organizations which release really
frequently have lower defect rates than
organizations that release infrequently
so just work out which side of the
equation that you want to be on because
you can't have your cake and eat it it
turns out so if you are in a situation
where you've got a release train try and
move away from that see it as a
transitory stepping stone towards better
mechanisms for deploying your software
if you're stuck with a release train
because of your architecture or your
organizational structure fix those
things but do not see this as a
destination because even if you end up
with it we start with a lovely beautiful
well factored architecture it won't stay
that way for long
you know the distributed monolith
fundamentally is not a great place to be
and I have certainly worked in
situations where I've advocated merging
things back together to properly
redefine the service boundaries again
before splitting it back out if you
can't find ways to do some change these
things independently you may well be
better off with a modular monolith
although I'd suggest if you're having
trouble with this you might find a
modular model it's difficult as well
what we're aiming for here fantastic
it's all right it's not on this stage
what we're aiming for here is is
architecture which enables continuous
delivery and that's you know that's not
surprising to me because I got into
micro services because I was originally
someone who focused on continuous
delivery how do I help people ship
software more quickly and I realized
often the architecture that we had was
one of the main inhibitors so I started
looking at these architectural styles
that allows this that makes it much
easier for us and lo this is about
organizational aspects this there's
architectural aspects as well making
this sort of stuff possible it's not
trivial work but it is worth doing when
it comes to breaking down the monolith
though we've got to think
about what we're breaking it down into
and this is where domain-driven design
comes into play so I know this is
something I think gets understated
there's too much fixation on the
technology side of this there's too many
people talking about kubernetes and
service meshes and and those things are
great and useful but are really fairly
uninteresting if you fundamentally get
your logical architecture on domain
driven design ends up being incredibly
useful to us here micro services are
modeled around business domain we're
looking for high cohesion of
business-related functionality and the
reason we want that is because once
reduce the cost of change if my business
functionality is smeared all over my
system a simple change in functionality
may require changes across multiple
services then I'm back into a world of
lots of release coordination and
potentially a slippery slide into a
distributed monolith so we're looking
for our ways to group our system
logically into components which have
high cohesion of business functionality
and domain driven design it's a great
way of doing this the original book sort
of on this was the the blue book by Eric
Evans it's a really good book I know a
lot of people have struggled with it so
I would suggest probably the starter I
would start with domain driven design
distilled by Vaughn Vernon Vaughn's here
the conference I haven't had a chance to
say hello yet but I'm sure he's doing
some talks you should definitely go and
see him these two be great introductions
when I'm working with a team to do a
system decomposition we starting with
the monolith one of the first things
we'll do is we'll say look we need to
come up with a domain model that
represents what the scope of this
monolith is because the reality is your
monolith is just a big mass of code it's
probably what Brian Foote calls a big
ball of mud it is not going to be
structured nicely around business
concepts it's going to be something
that's grown organically over time sort
of like a fungus and so we need to bring
at least a sense of what the logical
ordering or modeling in here could be
and so carrying out a domain modeling
exercise says okay if we think about how
people use this system and the mental
models they have and the business
processes we're operating we can come up
with a domain model now that domain
model may not match how the code is
organized but it does represent what it
does
and it also represents a model that we
would like to use going forward for our
services architecture and so you start
to sort of get a sense of okay where are
the different groupings of functionality
inside this monolith and I use the
normal user technique like events
storming and slowly what you'll stop
will start happening it's out of the
ashes of this model it'll start saying
okay well these are kind of the
groupings of functionality we've got so
in a situation here we've got invoicing
and order management and loyalty
management and notifications
functionality and any good domain model
also give you a sense of how these
concepts are related and so straightaway
we've got an interesting picture we're
starting to build out we have a logical
representation of what our monolithic
system does hopefully as a directed a
cyclical graph of dependencies if it's
not a directed a cyclical graph of
dependencies you have an issue because
circular dependencies are kind of tricky
to implement so we started already we're
getting useful information because one
of the big things we got to think about
is where do we start our decomposition
journey we've got this big monolithic
system and Manas do not start you know
on day one they take years to grow
nurturing huge amounts of investment
you're not going to kill this thing in a
week even if that was your goal it's
going to be a multi-year journey so you
start thinking about well how could we
bake bright light off the first piece
this logical model is already giving you
some information that makes it easier to
reason about where you might want to
start so look at this and think well
look wouldn't it be great if we
extracted the notifications
functionality but you realize that
looking at your logical domain model
that that is likely to be quite
difficult because it's such a core
domain concept inside your system
therefore it's likely to be a problem to
extract from a code point of view lots
of parts your system are going to need
to use that notifications functionality
so if you want to extract that and rip
that from the still-beating heart of
your mainframe it's likely to have it be
a lot of work because you're gonna have
all of these inbound dependencies that
are going to have to be rerouted instead
you can start thinking about things
further up in the stack that might be
less enmeshed in the center of your
system and may be easier to extract this
is quite useful exercise and then you
should follow this up by actually
looking at what the codes telling you to
these month how
far apart of these things sometimes the
right answer is to refactor your model
if a little bits as the code more
adequately represents these ideas it
guess makes it easier to move the
challenge of course with this is that we
can approach is purely from a technical
point of view and sort of exclude all
understanding or context of our business
because here's the thing monoliths are
not inherently bad micro-services aren't
inherently good and the goal is not to
have micro-services right who cares
about that you don't become successful
because you have micro-services your
customers do not care great about micro
services they are a micro so his
architecture is something you might
choose to adopt because it's going to
help you fix some problems that your
current architects you can't fit fix
right you're trying to use a markzware
architecture to achieve something else
it might be faster time-to-market
it might be to handle scale better it
might be to improve the robustness of
your application it might be to allow
more people to work side-by-side without
getting in each other's ways those are
the goals a micro service architecture
is just a means to an end and there are
other means to that ends as well so the
thing you're trying to achieve the goal
you're looking for will also factor into
how you think about prioritizing that
decomposition because on the one hand we
can think okay what is he what's the
easy stuff for us to drag out of this
system but you've got to balance that
and trade that off against those things
you're actually trying to achieve for
example I might find a piece of
functionality that pops out really
nicely as a lovely well factored service
but it's a piece of code that hasn't
changed in the last 10 years and it just
works and if my goal is to ship software
more quickly why am i spending my time
extracting functionality which we
haven't changed for ages and have no
plans to change so straightaway you've
got to bring that thinking in as well we
can all you end up with a bit of a
trade-off is certainly initially because
initially you do want some quick wins
you want to get a couple of services
extracted get those things into
production start learning from those
experiences as quickly as possible
because I just how we do things right
and you want a nice quick win you want
to get confidence because as you do this
you'll get better at it
process you'll work out the skills
technology and techniques that work in
your context so you want to adopt a sort
of an incremental approach to this
journey so you end up sort of trading
these things off in the one hand you've
got how easy is it to extract this piece
of functionality into a micro service
and you're trading that off against the
benefits of decomposition and that's
what we're trying to deal with I also
know just pause for a moment and and
just reiterate a point I made earlier
the monolith has sort of become this
sort of replacement word for a legacy
system and so that people are just
assuming that monoliths are inherently
bad systems right the malla
fundamentally isn't the enemy your goal
is rarely if ever to kill the monolith
in these situations all it is is if the
malefic architect's you have right now
isn't working for you you're looking to
change it enough so it does the vast
majority of monolith migrations I've
seen involved taking out a small portion
of the functionality from the monolith
it's the function as you care about the
most for whatever reason and quite often
the monolith continues to live he's just
doing less stuff than it did before the
monolith has become a micro leaf maybe
maybe that's for my next book not all
monoliths are bad some monoliths bring
us inspiration and knowledge and maybe
you know kickstart evolution who knows
and some some somewhat questionable
makeup anyway right the key thing I
wanted you to take away from this part
of the talk is to remember you do
actually need a good reason for your
migration if you don't have an
understanding about what it is you're
trying to achieve as a result of your
micro service migration it's going to be
problematic for you because you will not
understand how to prioritize your work
and then you're just like well what are
you doing well you're just creating
micro services for sake of it
it might be great for the CV but it's a
pointless waste of time right so you
what is it you're trying to achieve and
ideally you should be able to articulate
that goal in terms of something that
your end users would care about once
you've got a sense of what you're trying
to achieve you can prioritize it oh it
would be great if we could extract this
this would give us so many benefits here
but oh look it's really difficult and
you can use the consultants friend to
help you now yes the quadrants so
we have a quadrant and so going from
left to right we've got things which
will give us more benefit if we extract
them from bottom to top we have things
that are easier I mean it's not you put
them out you do some analysis you say
I'd love to extract this but it's really
difficult I'd love to extract this
actually looks really easy great let's
pick some of those things it's really
not rocket science right we're looking
for these quick wins things that we
could do quickly and easily that would
give us some benefit to help us get our
releases out more quickly we're looking
for this incremental decomposition we
want to be taking small parts out of our
monolith extracting them deploying them
into a production environment
integrating them with the monolith a lot
of this is a learning journey you're
going on a lot of the learnings from
this it's partly yes the work of
extracting the monolith but most of your
education is going to come from running
these things in production that's where
the scary stuff comes from first that's
what the stuff you can't necessarily
prepare yourself for get one
microservice extracted from your
monolith integrate the monolith and the
Micra service together get it deployed
into production sit with it for a bit
and then think about what you've done
and then decide should we do it again or
was this a really bad idea
right I get sick and tired of people who
extract this but they take a year out of
doing any feature delivery they couldn't
they transform their monolith into a
hundred fifty microservices and then
they deploy the whole thing at once and
I get a phone call saying Sam it's
really slow and we don't know what's
causing it it's like yes that will
happen right don't don't get full into
those traps that the days of the Big
Bang rewrite are over we can't afford
that sort of stuff anymore because our
customers want software to be delivered
right Big Bang rewrites were great when
your customers expected to get software
delivered once a year or once every two
years you had a year window in which you
could pretend you could rewrite the
whole system while no one was looking
now your customers want software to be
delivered every week or every day some
of the times these Big Bang rewrites
don't work and and as Martin will point
out the only thing we guaranteed with a
Big Bang rewrite is a Big Bang and
they'll look I love an explosion in an
action film I don't necessarily want Big
Bang's in my IT projects so if we're
thinking about
so is migration and we don't want these
big bang rewrites we want to keep
delivering features to our customers we
have to find patterns that allow us to
incrementally decompose our micro
service architecture because what we
want to be able to do is get good at
changing our architecture at the same
time as actually delivering new features
well the most useful patterns are
actually here is a surprisingly simple
looking pattern that comes in handy very
often that's a pattern called the
strangler fig pan it's actually named
after a type of plant noise live in
Australia I loved living out there as
many of you may be aware all the things
in Australia want to kill you the people
are nice right but all the things on the
land want to kill you're the animals on
the land this this the weather that
wants to kill you the sea that wants to
kill jellyfish and sharks even the
plants can be quite vicious this is a
strangler fig it's a type of figures
about twelve to species it's actually a
photograph taken in a rainforest in
Queensland and what they do is they take
root in the frost canopy so upon the
tree line so not on the floor but up
well the leaves are and they extend
their tendrils down they wrap themselves
around trees and they take root in the
soil and over time they grow up and
become bigger stronger vines that start
to look like trees so we're actually
seeing here is the vine on the outside
wrapped itself around the tree now once
that vine has built itself up enough it
becomes a tree in its own right and if
the underlying tree was built on dies
and rots away the tree doesn't care that
the vine carries on living looking now
like a tree and so it's sort of this
idea of taking existing structure in
this case a tree wrapping the vine
around it the vine couldn't stand up by
itself it needed something else to be
supported on and then once it's replaced
it you can take the tree away if you
want
so Nature has a way of you know dealing
with these things so in our software
terms this can also be useful to us
because we can wrap our incrementally
wrap our micro-service architecture
around our existing monolithic
architecture allowing us to build on top
of the model if make use of the moment
if make use of the important aspects of
the monolith but incrementally my great
functionality away from it and the nice
thing about these stronger applications
is motely strangler fig patterns is they
work very well actually for third party
products because they can offer
just work at the API level of these
systems when implementing Australia
patent this is a pattern that works
generically across other types of
architectures well you got kind of two
building blocks right you got what's
called asset capture this is the process
of identifying the functionality that
you want to move so in our case we would
be doing this by doing some domain
modeling exercises say ok this is the
functionality that logically now needs
to move and then what you need to be
able to do is you need to be able to
intercept calls to their old the old
location of that functionality and
divert them somewhere else instead this
is actually written out really nicely
over on Martin Fowler site and he's the
person that came up with this pattern
name now when we talk about movement of
functionality it might be that you're
actually copying and pasting code from
an existing system it turns out that
doesn't happen as much as I would like
partly because people have often got to
the point where I know logically we do
invoicing in here but the code is
everywhere in this monolith and it would
take us weeks to refactor that code to
find it let alone move it often as well
you might be changing technologies stack
as you move to my experience
architecture although I don't like doing
that I would rather when you do your
migration at least initially you keep
all of your technology choices the same
because I think you've got enough stuff
going on right if you're a PHP shop
build micro sources and PHP for a while
before you start trying to change your
programming language so you might be
lucky and be able to find the code and
copy it and a copy is the important word
not cut copy often though what people
didn't up doing is they rewrite that
small piece of functionality you're
breaking down that rewrite there you I'm
only having to rework the piece of
functionality that I'm aiming to move so
I've got to re-implement that logical
boundary so giving example of my point
the most simple way of implementing a
strangler fig and this is works really
well with any kind of system that's
driven via HTTP so in this example here
this could be a monolithic system where
we're intercepting HTTP underneath the
user interface so calls are coming in
from a UI this also could be a headless
application this could be actually I've
done something similar to this with
Salesforce where fxe Salesforce is the
monolith behind HTTP so the first thing
we're going to need is some kind of
proxy and it's actually something you
would do straightaway first one easy
just stick a proxy
between upstream calls and your monolith
and that proxy does absolutely nothing
it just routes all calls through and we
get that into production the reason we
do this cuz it's not doing anything
functionally different for us but it's
quite important what we've done is not
just given us a place where we can
intercept and redirect calls later on
but we're also starting to understand
the implications of adding Network hops
so in this situation a call user comes
straight into your monolith now it goes
viral proxy now that shouldn't add more
than a few milliseconds of latency to
your system it's a good idea to find out
if you've got a really crap Network as
early as possible if this increases the
latency of your calls by say 500
milliseconds you need to stop because
you cannot do micro services on a
network like that one of the clients I
work with years ago we had whole kinds
of performance issues with our system
until we realized that because of how
the networking was configured all calls
between our services were going via a
second country I think are doing being
routed via Luxembourg now that adds
latency that's not good right so find
that out first just put this in keep an
eye on the request times run it for a
couple of weeks make sure you're happy
you may already have an existing proxy
that you could use to do this for this
purpose it'll just depend on who's in
control that proxy you might want to put
your own in so you've got control over
what's happening next you start building
your service you can start implementing
your service you can be deploying your
brand-new micro service into a
production environment you can be
testing it in situ and it is safe to do
so because right now no one's calling it
the call set functionality are still
being served by the monolith when you're
confident that your new service is ready
you just change the proxy configuration
to rewrite the call that was going to
your monolithic system and you route
that instead over to your brand-new
micro service architecture so this could
just be a straightforward proxy
configuration you could get fancy and do
this with some kind of release flag
system although there's a lot to be said
we're just you know an entry Dan nginx
file and over time you can keep
diverting more and more functionality
away now we have to deal with state we
haven't talked about data and state here
we're going to come back to that a bit
later on but I have uses multiple times
to great effect not just for micromesh
migrations but also for monolith
migrations as well
of mine Paul Hammond a she's on a nice
write-up of different applications of
the strangler a strangler fig pattern
from a number of different projects if
you wanna get an overview of where it
can be used again one thing I do want to
point out here though is although the
implication of that picture you can see
there in Paul's post is that the goal is
to kill the monolith in my experience
it's extremely rare that that is
actually the business goal unless you've
really got a burning platform like this
is a mainframe system and all the people
that know how to code in it are dead
right normally you're just moving enough
stuff away until there's a reason to
come back and do the rest the nice thing
about these strangler figs pattern usage
is it allows you to stop at any stage in
net migration this is also the problem
with a Big Bang rewrite you're nine
months into finishing a 12-month rewrite
and suddenly your budget gets pulled we
haven't released anything you've got
nine months of just value gone away but
here if you stop a third of the way in
you've got a third of the value released
and deployed which is really valuable so
the strangler fig works really well when
you've got the stuff sort of saw up up
at the top of your call stack let's see
if this is gonna work yeah so up here
right so I invoice seeing all the
management stuff like that those are
kind of things that if they're the top
of the call stack of your model it could
be quite easy to grab and intercept but
what about when you've got things that
are sort of deeper inside your logical
stack like I can't intercept a call that
sends a notification to one of my
customers I can't intercept a call that
increments loyalty points in my in my
loyalty account because those are sort
of done side effects of other things
happening so if I want to start
extracting this functionality this is
when I do need to get my hands dirty
another pattern that works really well
here again allowing us to do this in an
incremental fashion
it's a pattern called branch by
abstraction so branch by abstraction is
often used by people who do trunk based
development to avoid the need for
branching in source code but it's really
useful here because it opens up some
nice interesting rollout mechanisms the
way branch by abstraction works is
firstly you've got to Cle create a clean
abstraction around the piece of code
that you're going to change so this
would require you to do some refactoring
of your monolithic system so you'd be
grabbing all this invoicing Codel and
notifications code together and putting
in a box we sometimes call these boxes
classes switch on those some of you
might be aware of right so you don't
make it
class or something like that then we
need an abstraction a switching
abstraction point and that could be as
simple as basically having that class
and then re routing all the calls into
that class and now rather than just
directly calling out to you know SMTP
servers or whatsapp api's they now come
to your nice and notifications class to
use that functionality and you know what
already if you do nothing else you've
made your monolith better all right and
maybe you'll be brave enough to make the
rest of your monolith better without
having to build a mic so its
architecture but I'll leave that for you
to consider so now we need the ability
to switch between this implementation of
the functionality where our loyalty
points are our notifications are sent
inside our process bounty are handled
inside this monolith and we need to
create an implementation that's going to
call out to our services so once we've
done this of first step we then create
an abstraction point that allows us to
switch implementations and that could be
as simple as having an interface for
your class
the current interface of that you
implement is the current monolith
implementation so you could call it the
monolithic notifications class that
implements the notifications interface
if you say wish so next you start
working on the new implementation this
service calling implementation is really
just going to be a bunch of client calls
that are going to call out to your
service like this right at this point
you will be you'll be checking this in
this has be something you'll be working
on while doing other features you'll be
checking this in to the same piece of
code you can coexist
both implementations cleanly because
only one of them is the live code path
and that's the existing implementation
you can be deploying your brand-new
service into production and testing in
situ which gets a release process you're
happy with and that's safe to do so
because it's not yet in the live code
path once you're happy that the things
are working appropriately you basically
just switch which implementation of the
abstraction you're using this could be
done it's a typically done with a
feature flag the nice thing of course is
we haven't removed the old code if
there's a problem we just flicked the
implementation back this could be a this
would normally be a cookie this might be
a compile time flag it could be a start
up time or even a runtime build toggle
there's lots different ways of making
that stuff work once you're really
confidently it's working well you might
decide to anicut you'd nearly always
clean where you definitely clean up the
feature flag once you no longer need it
you may
actually at that point also decided to
remove the old code from the monolith
and now you're shrinking the monolith
wouldn't that be nice like you're
starting to slowly chip away that
functionality that last cleanup step is
often optional and many people just
leave that code lying around now that
process of getting code refactoring it
behind a box kratie not a nice
abstraction knowing how to do that well
we've obviously got the refracting book
from Martin fan of the the latest
edition actually came out the beginning
of this year as well worth a read but
for this specific purpose I'd also
recommend with this book by Michael
feathers working effectively with legacy
codes an excellent book which talks
about how you basically refactor code
bases that might be a bit old
Michael's definition of legacy code is
code without tests which is you know
kind of valid and I think it works quite
well here this branch by abstraction
patent because we can coexist both
implementations in the code base at the
same time aside from reducing our merge
pain and a need for branches it also
opens up patterns like a parallel run so
with a parallel run pattern I can
execute both implementations in
production at the same time so whenever
a call comes in I send that call to both
the existing implementation and the
brand-new implementation at once now
this would be a terrible idea if you
were doing this for sending emails
because you do not want to send emails
twice but this can work quite well as a
comparison mechanism the same calls
coming in both pieces of functionality
of being executed and you can validate
are they coming up with the same answers
because this is a true refactoring we're
not trying to change the functionality
of the software so we should get the
same answers I've used it for
calculations before in something an
investment bank where we would run all
of our pricing for these certain
financial trades in parallel and at the
end of each day we'd have an excel sheet
that came out with any discrepancies and
then we'd go back and check why were
those numbers different sometimes we
found we'd accidentally fixed bugs and
sometimes our client may have put the
bugs back in our new system but you know
what can you do I spoke to a real estate
company up in Switzerland
called home gate and they actually did
effectively a parallel run like this for
their in for the listing upload system
from their real estate agents so they
actually run both systems in parallel
with when you've got both in point
patience coexisted inside the same run
time you open up some really interesting
possibilities like this to validate that
your software's working correctly and
you can even also use it to do quite
fine-grained canary rollouts as well
inside that malefics stack we haven't
talked about data and state much and we
have to think about that because well
you know in this situation I've taken my
own voicing code I've ripped that out of
the monolith but unfortunately my
invoicing service actually needs to
access data to do its job and right now
of course all the data lives in the
monolith and specifically in the
monolithic database so we got to think
well how do I get hold of my data so
well one option is just just just just
go get the data right just go get it
just directly access the Mullis database
now I'm I'm going to assume you're all
grown-ups here this is not a good idea
as a long-term strategy if you're doing
it for a couple of weeks or a few weeks
before completing the migration fine but
be honest with yourselves because if you
leave this in place you'll end up with a
distributed model it's the fastest way
to get a distributed monolith is have
lots of services all talking to the same
database because it creates huge amounts
of coupling of implementation coupling
okay so this is only something I would
count ins doing for a very short period
of time your micro service migration of
this invoicing service is not complete
if you've got this line in the mix the
reason for this is we like to think
about our micro services as being black
boxes the focus is on end-to-end slices
of business functionality that means we
need to include the data storage
we don't want outside parties reaching
straight into our database because it
becomes impossible for us to separate
what is shared from what is hidden
we now have external parties coupled to
our internal implementation detail this
is why you start getting into the
problems where I make a change here and
it breaks someone here Leslie Lamport
says a distributed system is one where a
computer I never heard of starts my
computer from work from working and this
is a fantastic way of doing this have
all of your storages talk to a database
then go and rename a column and see what
happens and guess what you'd only find
out in production so instead we want to
think about services
if they want information from you that
you hold they come and ask you for that
information via well-defined service
interfaces that allows you to decide
what you shared or what is hidden it
also makes it obvious to you as to who
your consumers actually are so none of
this backdoor access of databases get
rid of that you'll thank me later
and it's really again is a cutting edge
idea called information hiding that only
comes from 1970 so in this situation
invoicing these some data so we've got
to think about what is the data the
invoicing needs if the data that I need
is data that's really still owned by the
monolith so if you think about it some
are domain model point of view my
invoicing service needs to get
information about orders the orders are
still logically managed by the monolith
invoicing doesn't manage orders
therefore it's appropriate for me to go
and ask the monolith for the information
I want and so what I need to do is
expose some kind of service interface on
the monolith itself in this situation
I've exposed an API but this could be an
event bus or some other projection so
I'm gonna go and ask them on if please
can I have some of the information I
like and now I'm accessing the database
indirectly and I'm also starting to
define a new API here which could be the
sign of another micro service that might
want to emerge later on this is really
useful so the data you want is owned and
managed by another piece of code go to
that code and ask it to get the data you
want and this might help you start to
realize you know what behind the scenes
here I think this is maybe another
service that wants to be extracted it's
calling out to me so then you can get
that mice and you can see how that might
continue you might then pull that orders
service out and you pull another piece
out it's often what's happened you start
putting a piece of string and it always
more not so come out with it on the
other hand this is the more tricky
undertaking what if the data you want is
actually data you should be owning and
managing if we think about sort of
services as encapsulating state machines
the state that needs to change the
entire state machine is inside that
service I need my data locally please
give me my data well in that situation
we've got to get the data from here over
to
here so the source of truth the system
of record for invoicing related data is
now the invoicing service and so too
it's probably an obvious thing now we'd
need to invert that relationship we now
need to change the monolith to come to
the invoicing service for the data it
needs and actually that branch by
abstraction pattern we shared earlier
would be a great technique to make that
work the kind of tricky bit is that
whole see what I did there is I just do
some animations and I made a database
split apart fortunately it's a bit more
tricky than that so putting databases
apart is not fun but it is important
that you do it there's a whole bunch of
technique so let's go run through a
couple of example refactoring so give
you some ideas about the types of
trade-offs that this can cause and and
the challenges you may face but also
show how it is very much possible so if
you're interesting doing some proper
database refactoring I think this is the
best book on database view factoring
because I think it's the only book on
database refactoring it is actually very
good though as well it's sort of the
database refactoring equivalent of
martin fowler's refracting book i would
also suggest you do this work in concert
with any change tool that allows you to
define incremental sequel delta scripts
that can be version controlled and run
in a deterministic fashion that sounds
quite long-winded just use Flyway DB
that's the easiest thing just go use
Flyway and you'll thank me later don't I
don't like these database tipping tools
to this purpose I think Flyway is a much
better idea let's take a look at the
first example refactoring of a database
that we're trying to split apart so this
is our sort of monolithic music shop
I've been using the same domain for my
talks for a long time we are still
against all odds
selling CDs online I didn't claim that
we're making any profit but it's our
core business and we're committed we
decide to split apart our micro service
architecture inside our monolithic
system we've identified our catalog
related functionality and our finance
related functionality and those are
going to be our two services that we're
going to want to extract at the moment
inside the database we've got the
catalog looks after that it's data in a
line items table sis gives you like you
have an ID that says ok this is this CD
is the the death polka Hits Vol to
and it's 15 kronor so death polka is a
mash-up of death metal and polka now I
thought I'd made that up and I was did
of course in Stavanger last year and
someone started playing me death polka
and it believe me it's all too real
so death polka the greatest hits of
death polka vol 2 and then we've got the
ledger which is where we store our
financial transactions and this is
obviously data that the finance code
cares greatly about one of the things
that we do is we generate a top 10 list
of our best-selling CDs and the easiest
way for us to do this is to effectively
do a select where we look at all the
records in the ledger for the last week
group them by the ID of the item that's
been sold to account sort by that count
we're getting a top 10 list now if we
did that just on the ledger table we'd
come back with just a whole load of ID's
where I want 10 IDs we weren't actually
the name of the album's that we've sold
so we would do a join operation we would
join those IDs against the line items
table might use an ID or something
called a SKU so stock keeping unit now
of course if we're going to make
catalogue and finance two separate
services this joint operation is a
problem because these will become two
different databases as well so we have
to sever that join that can't exist
instead what we're going to do is move
the join up into the application tier so
this is obviously going to have some
issues right so what we're going to end
up with is something that looks a bit
like this so now we've gone from doing
one database call and a join down in the
database we're now doing two database
round-trips an extra network copy in
between and the join operation is being
done the application tier I do not mean
to offend any of you but I suggest that
you will not be able to implement a join
operation as effectively and efficiently
as people who have been building
databases like this the last 40 years
they've got a lot of expertise in doing
effective and efficient joins so this is
almost certainly going to have increased
latency that might not necessarily be an
issue when you split databases apart
often you can make systems faster
because you can remove sort of
bottlenecks and allow for parallel
processing but if you split databases
apart and you're joining across that
date
this will have an impact though in our
case a top 10 list that we update once a
week who cares it's not an issue but it
might be so you've got to think about
that when you're looking to decompose
your database it's more to think about
of course we look inside are monolithic
schema here's our ledger we have a row
we have a SKU column that's a foreign
key relationship and that foreign key
relationship points the line items table
foreign key relationships in a
relational database improve the
performance of joins because it it
basically tells the database that these
things are connected you can carry out
you can generate things like secondary
indices to make these operations faster
but it also typically would give us
referential integrity it will ensure
that we can't delete row 1 2 3 here from
the line items table because if we do it
will say oh if we try to say hang on you
can't that's going to violate
referential integrity so we use our
database as a safety net to look for
data inconsistency it's worth reflecting
of course that when we do that we don't
rely on the database we'd normally have
our application also stop you from doing
these things the database is just there
to make sure you don't do it now of
course when we go to two separate
schemas we have nothing that's going to
enforce our referential integrity it's a
couple this we've also have got to ask
the question what is our foreign key now
in this example here I've changed the
foreign key to a non opaque
URI which some people might like to do
if they're building a rest-based system
so I fir placed that Franchi with
actually HTTP resource that you could
directly dereference now I don't know
anyone that does this I wouldn't do it
probably myself the reasons there's a
number of reasons firstly spitting
databases apart is scary enough without
also changing your you know rewriting
foreign key relationships in the
database secondly people are always
worried what if I change how our lookup
entries in the catalog thirdly in this
situation I don't want to look up one
item when I go from the finance service
over to the catalog service I'm going to
look up 10 so does this mean I'm making
ten separate HTTP round trips up we
wouldn't do that I want to make one call
and pass all the IDS in so normally
people would just leave us as saying one
two three so that means the finance
service now needs to know that when it
sees one two three coming out that skew
column if it wants to get that the
related resource is going to have to go
and fetch that from somewhere or have
that read in from somewhere
so that's--that some smarts are now
gonna have to be up in your application
the other thing of course is there's
nothing is stopping us introducing
inconsistency in our data so we have
some options option number one don't
bother just just let people delete stuff
in the catalog worst case scenario
your top 10 list says I don't know what
this is but you might have to change
your code right so you know our
bestseller this week was ID one to four
but someone deleted the record in the
database but we not great option number
two would be to maybe implement a
cascading deletes or some people just do
it do use events and do a cascading
delete so I delete a record from the
catalog I fire an event and the event
gets picked up by the finance service
and I use that to delete records in my
financial ledger if you want to go to
prison really quickly that's a great
option don't do that
if vensica could be useful in a deletion
case if I delete a row from the catalog
table I might fire an event and say this
item has been deleted my finance service
could receive that event and say ah ok
it's been deleted we're gonna take that
data and store that locally as a hot
historic memory of what that actually
looked like so you could use that to
solve the problem in a different way the
really bad option here is before you
delete something from the catalog check
if anyone else is using it that's a
nightmare because it effectively is an
explicit reverse dependency on every
single service it depends on you so now
the catalog needs to know all the other
services that might use its information
it needs to be gathered to able to go
and ask all of them are you using this
ID and even if you did all of that work
which by the way you absolutely should
not it's still not guaranteed to work
unless you also lock all of those remote
services because I could go out to the
finance service they are using entry one
two three I'm not using entry one two
three I say great okay I'll go and
delete the record and just as I've been
doing that you put a reference on entry
one two three the only way I can
guarantee that would work would be to
say okay I'm deleting it lock your
database I would do my deletion now
unlock your database doesn't that sound
like fun just say no rights in this
situation I would probably just not
allow deletion do a shadow delete
soldier problems the key things here is
a technologist point of view we can come
up with five or six ways to solve that
problem all of them have a business
impact they have impacts the way the
system is used they impact the users of
the system and so you would have to have
a conversation with your people who use
a system to ask them what the right
answer is now if this is the first time
they've heard about you building a micro
service architecture and making changes
they're going to go no no just don't
allow that case but I've got to why now
if you're doing a micro service
architecture you're implementing a micro
silica service architecture to solve
legitimate business problems legitimate
problems your users and stakeholders are
having and you've talked to your
colleagues about what you're doing and
got their input event storming exercises
for coming up with two main model a
great place to get people on board then
when you have this conversation it goes
a lot smoother it goes do you know how
he's splitting apart our system so we
can handle the customer load they go yep
great I want that yeah I want that too
but I need to do that but this is going
to happen if I do that what should we do
that's a much easier conversation so
they always when you start breaking the
system's apart you will end up creating
some situations where the behavior of
the system will change and you can talk
about the trade-offs from a
technological point of view but you're
going to need to get input from the
people use a system to understand what
the right thing to do is let's look at
another one last example I'll skip over
the the static reference data one kind
of give time for some questions let's
take a look at another one that looks on
the face of it to be quite a simple
decomposition so we have here our
monolithic system we've got our catalog
code in our warehouse code this is the
much earlier version of our architecture
very simple basic database and each
throwing a database looks like this we
have the name of the album that we're
selling we have the amount and we have
the number of items in stock okay so
this bit here seems related to a
catalogue service or a Catholic
functionality and the stock levels seem
very clearly something that the
warehouse cares about and normally what
you would do to track this down would be
to actually look at how your database
mappings are being used so if you're
going through Lync or hibernate you'd
actually should be able to track down
okay
both of these bits of code and loading
this table which ones care about this
the most can we spit along maybe those
of logical lines and so this example is
quite straightforward decomposition and
I'm sure many of you have done this kind
of database refactoring in your past but
we see we need to consider what happens
when when Finance and cattle have become
a so and warehouse and catalogue becomes
services in their own right let's
imagine a brave new world where we have
three whole services so here they are
the catalogue service the payment
gateway in the warehouse service now
when you build a distributor system you
have to deal with the fact that
sometimes you can't talk to bits of the
de tributo system this could be because
the service is actually down it could be
because of a temporary network timeout
it could be because someone's
disconnected to cable and all the
packets are falling on the floor and
you've got to stuff all the network
packets back in the cable before you can
reconnect it right these things will
happen with a simple distributed system
you see these bot equal partitions
infrequently so a partition is where one
part of a distributed system can't see
another part with a normal monolith the
single process model if they happen very
infrequently the more distributed the
system you have the more you are likely
you are to see them especially if your
network is poor it could be all sorts of
reasons and you have to think about what
do your should your system do when these
partitions occur sometimes they're so
short-lived that you can just work
around and through retries okay a
network timeout okay retry that up to
three times with an exponential back-off
in between that's a standard thing
connection libraries like hysterics and
poly do for you or service measures do
for you or offload some of that by
having a message broker to handle
guarantee delivery later on fine but
sometimes there will actually be more
significant impacts let's take a look at
our our organization here we're selling
CDs online and for whatever reason we
are unable to talk to our warehouse and
our warehouse managers our stock levels
so we don't know what's in stock we know
how much something costs because that's
in the catalogue we can take people's
money because we've got a thin wrapper
around stripe and stripe is good and so
it will work right this is good but we
don't know if we've got any CDs in stock
this failure mode could not exist with
your monolithic system
because with your monolithic system
either the whole things up or the whole
things down now if we can tolerate this
particular situation then we actually
will make our system more robust because
we can maintain some operations even
when we have failure if we don't think
about this though we could end up with a
system that will decide what it wants to
do without us being involved
he's the question now I'm gonna ask all
of you in this situation we know how
much something costs but we don't know
if it's in stock but we can take
people's money put your hands up
should we keep selling CDs wait it has
you capitalist but right ok hands up if
we shouldn't sell CDs you naive fools
right um ecommerce companies they keep
selling the CDs in this situation the
reasons actually quite straightforward
they're business reasons if I sell you a
CD and take your money and then find out
I don't have the CD I go sorry I offered
to give you your money back or
optionally back order the CD on the
other hand if I don't sell CDs at all no
one's happy I'm not making any money I
can't sell the CDs I do actually have
and guess what my customers are annoyed
they can't buy the CD and they'll go buy
it somewhere else anyway and they won't
come back so that's why CD companies
make that switch trains the business
domain we're sitting concert tickets you
get a very different answer I think I've
got tickets to see a hidden Metallica
geek they're playing in a small club
around the corner next week my friends
are flying over from Stavanger and
Trondheim we have a great party our
sorry you don't really have any tickets
the amount of pain and suffering to your
custom in that situation is distinctly
different you can't back order a ticket
for an event
so normally ticket companies in this
situation will shut them down because
they know you'll come back why because
they're the only ones are the tickets
right so different business contexts you
make a different choice
this actually this trade-off is actually
based on something called cap theory
this is a much crap theories you ever
need to know cap Theory basically says
that when you have a partition you have
to trade off between consistency and
availability when we take the money
we're saying it's more important that we
maintain the ability to sell CDs that
availability that operation is more
importantly important than having a
consistent view of our data when we
don't take the money we're saying
consistency of our system is more
important to us than availability of
that operation this is as much cap
series you ever need to know if someone
ever tells you you can beat cap theory
you can't don't worry about it it is a
common-sense trade-off but again you can
have to take your customers on that
journey with you we are over time I
apologize for that I'm going to happy to
hang around for questions up we got on
the side but thank you so much of your
time if you want to see more stuff
there'll be the slide to be up by
website later today and more information
about a new book is there thank you
[Applause]